a futter wagon dance an undercover
horror a bomber plane fighting a dragon
these trailers were loved by millions
the actual movies not so much
in an era of unnecessary sequels it's a
surprise Zoolander 2 took so long 15
years after the first installment
morphed from box office bomb to cult
comedy classic audiences were ready to
see blue steel flash across the screen
again then the trailer dropped and it
was great all of our favorite characters
were back Benedict Cumberbatch looked
like an androgynous alien mugatu's hair
was looking fresh as ever and we even
got to see Justin Bieber get
assassinated this was the triumphant
return of early 2000s Nostalgia with 22
million views and 87 000 likes on
YouTube the world was clearly ready
cold
Lemay and then we saw the movie it was
okay there wasn't much to laugh at and
the movie just rode on a wave of
nostalgia only offering twists on the
same jokes from the first movie
honestly we should have known when in
the trailer we saw mugatu throw coffee
on his assistant again everybody in the
movie looked bored just going through
the motions and no amount of Justin
Bieber cameos could save it even the
magnum look couldn't stop the bad
reviews everybody forgot they saw it
within a week sending any hope of
further sequels Up in Flames faster than
a gasoline fight accident
in the pre-youtube Dark Ages watching
movie trailers was hard you had to know
which films the trailers were attached
to and hope your theater was showing the
right ones when the trailer for The
Phantom Menace dropped fans were so
hyped that they bought tickets to other
movies just to see the trailer not even
staying for the movie afterwards all
through November 1998 theaters sold out
tickets to films Like A Bug's Life only
to have seats empty out before the
opening titles even rolled Star Wars was
back despite how the end product turned
out the phantom menace trailer was damn
good the opening shot of a fog-covered
swamp with the force theme playing is
still spine tingling all the visuals
look awesome and even the awkward Yoda
lines feel epic it's so good that it
almost makes us want to go back and
watch episode 1 again almost
nobody needs to be reminded of how the
movie actually turned out by now it's
achieved meme status as a symbol for
incredible disappointment now this
[Music]
whaling doesn't top many lists of things
I want to see in movies but in the heart
of the sea looked like it was ready to
change that for us this trailer had
everything beautiful cinematography cool
special effects shots without revealing
the monster and Thor looking tough
holding a spear what's not to love the
trailer was so good that 4.7 million
people watched it many of whom never
even knew they wanted to see a whaling
movie turns out the only good things
about the movie were in the trailer
Chris Hemsworth Killian Murphy and
Brendan Gleason are talented actors Ron
Howard is a competent director and knows
how to put together an interesting story
but it never connected with the audience
on an emotional level most of the movie
was just characters yelling at each
other and since none of the characters
were fully developed in the heart of the
sea was ultimately just a slock all it
did was prove that not even Chris
Hemsworth's Rippling muscles and sexy
hair can save a bland script something
we should have already known from Thor
the Dark World
most movie trailers are just slapped
together scenes from the movie but if
you are so expertly made that they
become pieces of art on their own battle
Los Angeles had such a trailer opening
with shots of UFO sightings from around
the world it gave us a feast of the best
visuals from the movie Set to Johan
Johansson's haunting part 5. the movie
looked breathtaking but also grounded in
realism promising a mixture of Saving
Private Ryan and Independence Day this
was going to reinvent the Alien Invasion
genre or so we expected sadly in reality
battle Los Angeles was a bland
hodgepodge of Tire tropes from war and
science fiction movies
reaction scenes were fine and the Alien
Invasion story was mildly interesting
but there wasn't much else to talk about
and all the cool parts of the movie were
in the trailer the trailer was so good
in fact that two years later Edge of
Tomorrow copied the feel of it only this
time the movie actually delivered on its
trailer's promise
we have to hand it to DC though the
trailer for Batman vs Superman is Super
Rad and it pulled in 57 million views
and 332 000 upvotes with many of its
dislikes coming after the movie was
released it's easy to see why people
loved this trailer Batman looks awesome
and seeing him together with soups made
everybody giddy the voiceovers paint a
chilling and realistic picture of how
the human race would actually react if
Superman lived among them we wouldn't
just hold hands and love our alien
savior many people would be terrified
sadly even though that was technically a
theme of the movie The Light and
punching show overshadowed everything
else Zack Snyder has an eye for
storyboard design and that makes for
great trailers solid films on the other
hand are a completely different story
1982's Tron was steamrolled at the box
office but acquired a cult following
over the ensuing years a belated success
that Disney tried to capitalize on in
2010 with their stylish Daft Punk scored
Tron legacy decades after the original
whiffed the studio tried hard to make
Tron trending and with its awesome
trailer they almost succeeded there are
so many things to love about this
trailer it shows enough of the movie to
get audiences interested without giving
too much away the music is great and all
that bright monochromatic neon looks
awesome as hell picking up 14 million
views and tens of thousands of upvotes
the world was ready for a tron sequel we
have to admit the movie wasn't that bad
but it wasn't great either sure it was
pretty but visuals can only take a movie
so far at some point an interesting
story has to keep the audience hooked
and with Tron legacy that never happened
despite its excellent trailer it failed
to win over critics or restart the
franchise even today people only really
remember it for its soundtrack and maybe
that's the best way to look at it and
over long Daft Punk music video
if we were to draw up a list of
ingredients for a cool movie you'd find
most of them in the trailer for Sucker
Punch World War one dog fights dragons
machine guns trench warfare B-25 bombers
attractive girls fighting with guns
Zeppelin crashes this trailer has it all
why was that bomber plane fighting a
dragon who cares it looks cool in the
days before DC movies having Zack
Snyder's name attached to a project
actually helped build up hype after the
success of 300 we were ready to see
Snyder step into a gritty more modern
world and if its trailer was anything to
go by Sucker Punch stood poised to
redefine the action genre by bringing
steampunk into the mainstream with a
budget of 82 million dollars Sucker
Punch failed to even earn back half of
the Studio's investment domestically
although it made up much of the
difference overseas scathing reviews and
accusations of sexism poisoned the well
early on and nobody ended up seeing it
Prometheus isn't terrible but what
ultimately made the movie so
disappointing is that the teaser trailer
made this Alien prequel Side Story look
like the coolest science fiction movie
ever and a groundbreaking return to form
for director Ridley Scott the first
trailer does an amazing job finding the
right balance between getting the
audience comfortable with things we know
while introducing new elements the name
fades in just like alien and we catch
glimpses of all the trappings of the
original movie it shows off stunning new
visuals while setting a tone of ominous
mystery all within one minute it's a
master class in visual storytelling like
we said we don't hate the movie but it
never hits the same highs as alien
somehow the Mysteries here feel less
profound Prometheus has the odd
Misfortune of not really elevating The
Source material but also not destroying
it it's basically the after dinner mint
of the alien franchise Pleasant at the
moment but utterly forgettable once
you're done judging by the trailer
however it could have been much much
more
in a common theme among good trailers
for bad movies this first promo clip
made the film look much deeper than it
actually was with slow haunting music
dreamlike visuals and an ominous
voiceover this looked like the movie
that finally nailed the dark tone DC was
aiming for Jared Leto was delightfully
creepy as the Joker and Margot Robbie's
Harley Quinn looked like she'd stepped
right off a comic page hot off Deadpool
we were all ready for another adult
themed superhero movie what could go
wrong in a word post-production where
the film was edited to the point of
being incomprehensible following the
plot of Suicide Squad was nearly
impossible and no amount of Jared Leto
scenery chewing could save it
out of all the Zack Snyder movie
trailers on our list this one Hurts the
Most the third trailer for Man of Steel
might be the best ever made it's perfect
starting with slow piano music the
trailer pulls at our heartstrings fills
us with wonder and is more tear-jerking
than a commercial for a movie has any
right to be anybody who doesn't feel
chills when Superman launches into the
air needs to check their pulse the music
perfectly builds to the moment in the
immaculate editing drives the trailer to
its thrilling climax really it's a mini
movie too bad the full film never lived
up to it still the trailer exists and
it's worth watching again in fact we
still like to Imagine That Man of Steel
never came out and this is for a better
Superman movie still in production
please DC give us something as good as
this three minute short
Warner Brothers and legendary pictures
monsterverse franchise has always made
better trailers than movies from that
first Godzilla teaser which revealed the
coolest scene in the whole movie to that
incredible rhythmic Kong Skull Island
trailer inspired by the trailer to park
Chan wook's the handmaiden 2019's
Godzilla king of the monsters is the
series worst movie so far by critical
consensus and yet its trailer made it
look like a potential Masterpiece
monster movies like these naturally make
great trailers since the trailers get to
showcase the star attractions the
monsters without getting bogged down in
the often mediocre human side of the
stories the king of the monsters trailer
is extra impressive due to the use of
the claw Debussy composition Claire de
Lune the classical music creatively
contrasts with the bombast of the
imagery and creates a feeling of
emotional Transcendence the movie's
actual score is just as bombastic as the
action but the results were more
headache inducing than genuinely
exciting
Nicholas wending refund films lend
themselves to misleading trailers the
trailer for Drive actually became the
subject of a false advertising lawsuit
from a woman expecting a fast and
furious style action movie instead of a
slow atmosphere of drama but that 2011
movie went on to become a favorite of
critics and film fans alike not so with
only God forgives refin's 2013 follow-up
collaboration with actor Ryan Gosling
where drive one ref and a Best Director
award at can only God forgives was
greeted with booze at the same Festival
two years later from the trailer only
God forgives looked like an awesome
martial arts movie the actual film made
Drive look like a Non-Stop Thrill Ride
in comparison heightening everything
that made its predecessor alienating to
the mainstream like the long stretches
of silence and the sporadic bursts of
extreme violence without the appealing
story and solid emotional core that gave
Drive its cult status
timeout's Dave Calhoun wrote style over
substance doesn't really tell the half
of it you can bathe the corpse in groovy
light and dress it in an expensive suit
but in the end that rotting smell just
won't go away
when Superman Returns hit theaters in
2006 even those who liked the movie
often said that the best part of the
experience was seeing the trailer for
Spider-Man 3. Sam rainey's previous
Spider-Man films were among the best in
the whole superhero genre and this
looked like a culmination of everything
the series had achieved between the
intensity of the black suit scenes
stunning special effects for Sandman and
the promise of big payoffs for Peter
Parker's romance with Mary Jane Watson
and his friends to enemies Arc with
Harry Osborne Spider-Man 3 looked like
the must-see event of Summer 2007. the
actual movie couldn't possibly live up
to all that hype Spider-Man 3 turned out
to be a mess packed with too many
storylines and villains unable to give
each of them the attention they deserved
Rainey didn't even want Venom to be in
the movie but was pressured by producer
Avi arat and that lack of Interest shows
in the finished product rainy later
described the film as awful on the
Nerdist podcast the hatred for
Spider-Man 3 in some circles can be
overblown this deeply flawed movie still
has some highlights of action and humor
but the sheer disappointment of it can't
be overstated now dig on this
[Applause]
Ben Stiller's 2013 adaptation of James
short story The Secret Life of Walter
Mitty is the epitome of failed oscarbate
coming off directing 2008's Tropic
Thunder a wild satire of awards season
that managed to get actual Awards
nominations for Star Robert Downey Jr
Walter Mitty seemed like a move into
something more serious and inspirational
while still maintaining an element of
humor the film's first trailer set to
the song Dirty Paws by Of Monsters and
Men made it look like Stiller was going
to pull it off starting off with Walter
mitty's mundane routine of going to work
at Life Magazine the trailer soon
transforms into a surreal and epic
adventure with the images on the
Magazine's covers coming to life it's a
beautiful trailer while the movie itself
was just as visually stunning as
promised the storytelling ultimately
proved unsatisfying and over sentimental
bilga abiri's review for vulture
proclaimed exquisitely produced
immaculately acted and thoroughly
unevolving The Secret Life of Walter
Mitty is a perfect nothing of a movie
Mark Mohan of The Oregonian felt
similarly writing the movie is
beautifully shot but it's also a
blatantly manipulative piece of smarm
this was not the award season Behemoth
it was set up to be
writer director Randy Moore's 2013 Indie
Oddity Escape from Tomorrow a horror
movie shot undercover at the Disney
theme parks is the type of movie that
sounds much more entertaining in theory
than in execution it's no surprise that
it plays a lot better as a one minute
trailer than as a 90-minute movie
instead of the typical MPAA disclaimer
the trailer opens by announcing the
following motion picture has not been
approved for all audiences by the Walt
Disney Company the black and white
cinematography of Disney attractions
with surreal twists is punctuated by
press quotes emphasizing how amazing and
unbelievable it is that this film got
made notably those quotes aren't
actually talking about the quality of
the movie Once the shock and awe of its
initial Sundance Premiere wore off
critics were decidedly less impressed
New York Times critic AO Scott wrote
none of it is as scary or as funny as it
should be and what starts out as a Sly
Thumb in the eye of corporate power ends
up as a muddled and amateurish homage to
David Lynch
long before movie lovers were sick of
Disney churning out live-action remakes
of all of its animated Classics the idea
of a Tim Burton directed Alice in
Wonderland movie sounded potentially
wonderful Burton is at his best when
he's able to let loose with strange
imagery in Lewis Carroll's classic
children's books would seem like the
ideal playground to indulge as
creativity without worrying about his
relative weaknesses in conventional
plotting so of course the 2010 Alice in
Wonderland looked awesome in its
trailers which highlighted the
expectedly impressive production design
and special effects despite these visual
strengths however the actual movie went
against the spirit of its source
material by turning it into a painfully
generic Chosen One narrative basically
everything that was appealing about the
movie was showcased in the marketing and
all that was left for surprises in the
theater were such unappealing sites as
the Mad Hatter's futter wagon dance
Wonder Woman 1984 was one of the most
highly anticipated movies of 2020 and
ended up being arguably one of its worst
and certainly one of its most
disappointing
the trailer did an excellent job selling
the movie combining the girl power
action that made Patty Jenkins 2017
Wonder Woman so refreshing with a new
colorful and nostalgic 1980s setting and
style how could you not get hyped up by
that remix of Blue Monday from New Order
not having to reveal the film's more
questionable plot elements makes
everything look better than it was when
the new villain Max lore talks on TV
about getting everything you want you
might think you're in for a commentary
on the excesses of 80s capitalism rather
than a silly dream Stone plot line
life is good
but it can be better when the trailer
shows Steve Trevor back from the dead
and reuniting with Wonder Woman you
wouldn't even guess that their romance
would involve violating a total
stranger's consent but yes that's
actually in the film
foreign